[Music]
since the beginning of recorded history
civilizations have crafted creation
narratives Genesis from the
judeo-christian tradition is among the
most familiar but there are hundreds of
others the indigenous Australians speak
of the dream time where ancestral
Spirits shaped the continent across the
Pacific Polynesian folklore tells of the
night sky being the shell of a great
Turtle it surface the firmament upon
which we gaze many of these have
acquired sacred status as origin stories
often explain more than the mere
mechanics of creation but provide the
basis for addressing questions of
meaning and morality as guides for
navigating the complexities of Life many
have have found creation stories
essential while these stories have been
told from Millennia it was only in the
20th century that sence stepped onto the
stage with its own proposals for the
origin of the universe or at least how
the universe developed from a mere
instant after whatever process brought
it into
existence the keys to going Beyond
campfire storytelling were twofold first
telescopes began to peer beyond the
confines of the Milky Way galaxy
establishing that on large scales space
itself is expanding and second Einstein
painted the elegant mathematical
tapestry of the general theory of
relativity establishing that gravity and
the fabric of SpaceTime are intimately
entwined in a manner lay it out in the
equations Einstein spent 10 years
perfecting but even so for many years
the data was simply too coarse for
observation and Theory to provide
anything more than a broad brush
understanding that the early Universe
was hot and dense and underwent a period
of Rapid swelling during which it
expanded and cooled as the conditions
became less extreme structures such as
Galaxy stars and planets were able to
coalesce broad brush is now
transitioning to Fine Line as new
observational tools and refined
mathematical descriptions are making
cosmological Pursuits a Precision
science
so where does precision cosmology
currently stand how well do we
understand the early Universe what
puzzles and Mysteries do we still face
and perhaps most important of all will
we ever have a definitive understanding
of how the universe
began good
evening hi
there thank
you I'm Brian Green and thank you so
much for joining us tonight and you know
when you think about the questions of
science some of them are are
mindbending to scientists trying to
understand the details of this or that
quantity or quality of the world or
trying to understand some deep aspect of
some particular
experiment but the questions of
cosmology are of a different category
right these these are the questions that
that grab us all now when we ask where
do we come from how did it all begin and
these very questions as the piece just
laid out have captivated our ancestors
throughout recorded history and the
remarkable thing and if you take
anything away from tonight's program it
should be this we have
transitioned from a time when cosmology
was a subject of Storytelling coming up
with narratives that felt right or
suggested some quality of the world that
spoke to us in some poetic manner we've
gone beyond that where cosmology is now
a science where the measurements are
astoundingly precise allowing us to make
statements about things that happened
billions of years ago with a very high
degree of confidence but as that piece
just laid out there are still many
Mysteries the deepest of which no doubt
is do we know why there is something
rather than nothing what can we say
about the reason why there is a universe
at all and we are so honored and pleased
tonight to be joined by scientists who
are leaders in their disciplines and
will help us explore these vital
questions so let me bring them in now
our first is Eva Silverstein who is a
professor of physics at Stanford
University and is a Pioneer in
gravitation and string theory for her
pivotal contribution Silverstein was
awarded a MacArthur Fellowship thanks so
much for being here
Eva next up next up is Adam Reese who's
the Thomas J Barber professor in space
studies at John's Hopkins University and
a distinguished astronomer at the Space
Telescope Science Institute in 2011 he
shared the Nobel Prize in physics for
his discovery that the expansion rate of
the universe is accelerating Adam
welcome and finally our third guest Joe
Dunley who was a professor of physics
and astrophysical Sciences at Princeton
University in 2020 she was awarded the
New Horizons prize for her development
of Novel techniques to extract
fundamental physics from astronomical
data thanks so much for being here
Joe all right so briefly the plan of the
evening is to start here in chapter one
taking us through the history of
cosmology kind of bringing us up to
pretty much where we are today and then
we'll start to look at some of the small
cracks which may just be little cracks
that just need to be patched up but may
actually be the window into a revolution
in our thinking about Cosmic Origins and
finally we'll finish up by taking a look
at the future so let's begin with some
of the history and before we get into
the details I just want to try to give
the audience a sense of scale that we're
we're talking about here so you know we
say something like 13.8 billion years
ago when we talk about the universe Joe
how how do you think about a number that
is so radically different from a time
scale that we ever experience in
everyday life I think I try not to think
about it all at once you know the say
it's because otherwise it blows your
mind yeah it really does and so I try
and think about different scales and
different um it is a large number you
know it takes for examp I'm look we're
looking at light that's been traveling
for like 14 billion years and the solar
system only takes like 5 hours to get
you know from the Sun out to Neptune
it's but I I try and separate it I I
think about the larger scales and keep
it separate from you know everyday life
yeah I mean Adam does that just sort
of you know someone who's worked in this
field for decades someone who's you know
won a Nobel Prize for insights into
cosmology does the scales both in space
and time of the work that we're able to
do does it does it blow your mind still
or do you get kind of used to it yeah I
mean I think that uh you know if you sat
there in awe all the time you wouldn't
get your work done so you know you just
can't be sitting there going I cannot
believe I'm many zeros I'm I I have to
carry around so you know so at some
point you know you get you get your mind
around it and then you're doing math and
you're doing equations and you're doing
measurements and uh they're just very
big numbers yeah so Eva you know the
work that you the work that that
overlaps with things that that we've
done is often focused but not
exclusively in in the arena of string
theory and we'll talk about that gives
us insights into gravity that's a theory
that talks about the very small things
in the universe and one of the beautiful
things of the subject is that it Blends
insight into the small and the big
together how do you think about the tiny
scales that are relevant when you're
trying to understand the fundamental
ingredients in everything thing well
that's a wonderful question but first to
your earlier question let me say one
thing which is there are different ways
of measuring time and in fact maybe a
simpler way to think about it is that
the photons that Joe measures uh come to
us from when the universe was a thousand
times smaller than it is today yeah and
that's not as dramatic as a number um
and it's still blows my mind that you
know we are talking with a straight face
about what was going on 14 billion years
ago and part of that is the Quantum
origin structure so you ask where does
everything come from and it comes to you
know in a way that's been well tested
there's a great theory of it that just
comes from the Heisenberg Quantum
uncertainty principle in the context of
the accelerating early universe and so
uh in our minds it is vast and dramatic
but it's also getting us to you know the
essence of a physics and in some ways
it's a very simple Theory yeah um when
it comes to string theory it turns out
that when we parameterize our ignorance
of of those times in a way that's
principled that you know uh allows us to
start from long scales and move our way
to shorter and shorter scales we find
that that theory is sensitive to things
like string theory quantum gravity and
that's um in fact where my cosmological
interest comes in absolutely leading to
a beautiful interface between that
theory and observations so maybe we can
get into a little bit of the details the
the the origin or the beginning of
modern cosmology I think we can sort of
date that to you know the early years of
the the 20th century maybe
19617 around that time and it was
initially sparked by Einstein's
discovery of the general theory of
relativity so maybe AA maybe you can
begin you know what is it that Einstein
discovered in 1915 and and why is it
relevant to the subject that we're
talking about tonight well this was one
of the beautiful triumphs of of theory
we're going to talk a lot about
observation in in this session quite
rightly um but by thinking about the
thought what we call thought experiments
and how light and matter move um
Einstein uh through through various
processes discovered a theory in which
the motion of particles and light is
dictated by um them moving the shortest
way they can on some curved SpaceTime um
and conver ly the matter and light and
particles teaches SpaceTime itself how
to curve so there's some equations that
relate the two and um that's of great
importance in cosmology because the
universe itself is expanding and um
accelerating in its expansion and uh the
relation between curvature and energy
that goes into Einstein's equations is
you know intrinsic to that so basically
what you're saying is in Einstein's
approach a star like the sun it it warps
the space-time environment around it and
those warps and curves then guide the
motion of the planets that's why they
follow the particular orbits the
particular trajectories that they do
they're kind of sliding along the warps
and Curves in the fabric of space and
time and so it wasn't long Adam before
Einstein himself and then others as well
began to use the equations of the
general theory of relativity to not just
understand what we just saw the planet
say em motion around the Sun but to try
to understand the entirety of the
universe so you can take us through some
of the early attempts to do that yeah so
it's very interesting Einstein in many
ways was sort of about 10 to 15 years
ahead of his time for doing that problem
so Einstein was looking at solutions to
his equations that would govern the
entire universe and he immediately
recognized that the Universe could be in
motion uh but maybe not that he needed
to know something about what the actual
Universe does so he spoke to astronomers
of his day and asked them what does the
universe do is it moving or not and I
say it was about 15 years ahead of his
time because at that time astronomers
thought our Milky Way galaxy was the
whole universe and so they looked at
stars in the Milky Way which are not
moving all that fast and said it's
pretty static nothing really nothing is
growing bigger or smaller and Einstein
thought okay hm that's a little tricky I
would have thought you know gravity will
pull things together even in gr general
relativity but he made also an amazing
discovery that there was the potential
for another kind of energy in the
universe he called the cosm modal
constant whose gravity would be
repulsive it could balance this
attractive gravity so he thought he had
found the way to explain what the
astronomers were saying the universe was
static okay therefore there's the
attractive stuff and the repulsive stuff
Hubble comes along some 10 or 15 years
later measures how far away objects are
how fast they're moving and finds most
things are moving away from us uh the
further away they are the faster they're
moving away from us the only way to
explain that is if the universe as a
whole is expanding um Einstein comes to
learn this from Hubble and concludes
that he had been given essentially bad
information he had injected this cosmal
constant that we would will later refer
to as dark energy and which you win the
Nobel Prize for I might just say that is
true um and but it was it was
unnecessary at the time uh and so he he
famously said this was the biggest
blunder of his career um you know
blunders like that I I would uh be happy
to have more of them uh but uh anyway so
he he gets rid of it and now we have an
expanding Universe with a a simple story
of just matter in the universe up until
that point and before we delve into that
a little bit more fully you mentioned
Adam that Einstein's perspective was
driven by these conversations that he
had with astronomers I've also read but
I can't say that I've actually delved in
to make sure this is really true but I
wonder if anyone has here on the panel
Einstein also liked the idea of a static
Universe because a non-static universe
might suggest to beginning and he said
that felt too
biblical it felt too much like genesis
is that something that you well I just I
I I do I don't actually know that detail
but he did seem to be very anti the idea
of a a changing Universe yeah he seemed
to be very fixed on the universe being
as it was and that does actually ring
true that that could be the case and I
think I feel quite sorry for some of the
scientists at the time who were also
taking his beautiful equations and
realizing that that could mean that the
Universe was expanding or shrinking um
Alexander fredman is one one of the
George lametra is another they took his
beautiful equations and said hang on the
universe could be growing or shrinking
but Einstein hated it yeah I think and
the Matra interesting himself was both a
physicist and also a Jesuit priest
that's right so it was an
unusual combination and I don't know if
that played into Einstein's response
where you know I think he he famously
said to the Matra your your calculations
are correct but your physics is
abominable and and and even worse you
know lametra wrote this you know
beautiful paper saying there the
universe could be expanding I've also
seen some evidence for it but he wrote
it in French in a in a little red
journal and it wasn't translated
actually until after Edwin Hubble had
figured it all out so you know there
were these extra players yeah so so Eva
you know when we talk about an expanding
universe and It ultimately comes from
famous data that Edwin Hubble gave the
world back around
1929 we see that the farther away an
object is that's on the horizontal axis
the faster it is moving and that is
along the vertical axis and it's this
pattern of the greater the distance the
greater the recessional speed that gives
the evidence that the universe is
actually expanding but you got to be
able to look at something far away and
and determine its speed of of recession
if you want to argue that things far
away are moving away how do you do that
how do you measure the speed of
recession of something that's far away
in space all right so I think people are
familiar with the what we call the
Doppler effect so if something's moving
away but emits waves to us they're
they're what we call Red shifted they're
they're long they're longer um and so
that's a very beautifully simple way
yeah I think there's a little diagram
maybe it tell us what we're seeing here
here yeah so this uh it's hard to see
you can't see you can look back behind
you too if you want okay little bright
up here y I can't see any of you I
assume you're there um so yeah there's
there's an object moving away um and the
Observer of that will'll see uh that the
light is redder than it otherwise would
have been and that's indicated in the in
the in the diagram as as the waves
become redder because as space expands
the light gets stretched by the stretch
of space and that takes it sa from the
blue end of the spectrum more and more
toward the red end of the spectrum and
indeed the faster it's moving away from
us the more red the light will be
shifted one thing about the expansion
and especially the accelerated expansion
and Einstein's theory in general is that
it introduces not just you know the idea
of expansion and things aren't static
but Horizons so situations where we
don't get to see everything that's going
on um and that may bother some some
people but you know too bad it's it's uh
the speed of light is finite and so when
we look out we see quite a bit we see
back to this what translates to this 14
billion years um but we have every
reason to believe there's more beyond
that and and beyond our Horizon and and
and so I think we'll come a little bit
to cosmological Horizons a little bit
later on but in some sense if the
farther you go the faster things are
moving away at some point roughly
speaking they're moving away faster than
the speed of light which does not
violate the dictum that nothing can
travel through space at faster than the
speed of light because nothing
constrains the speed at which space
expands things that are moving way
faster than the speed of light we can't
see them so as you're saying we get cut
off from things that are sufficiently
far out there now a key part of this
idea so Hubble finds that distant
objects are moving away reports this
Einstein as you say kind of smacks
himself in the head and says H why
didn't I just trust you know my original
equations and so forth but now we can
Dig Down Deeper we can we can ask as as
actually Hubble did what's the expansion
rate and this is going to be an issue
that we're going to spend a little time
on later on so can you Adam can you tell
us sure how you talk about that and then
we will show a little visual to give a
feel for what it means yeah and perhaps
if we had that grid back showing the
expanding space um it that might help
people but you know the general idea is
when space is expanding it stretches
these wavelengths of light so we look at
something far away and when we look far
away we're looking back in time and we
are seeing uh over what time length if
something's 100 million light years away
we are seeing over a 100 million years
how much the wavelengths of Light have
been stretched by space and a good
number would be it'll be about 1%
stretching of the wavelengths of light
so uh therefore uh by measuring how far
away things are and how much how much
red shifted the light is you can measure
the expansion rate of the universe you
could express it in various ways one
ways you could express it you could say
the universal double every 10 billion
years that's an expansion rate but we
measure it using funny units that tie
very closely to what we actually observe
which is we observe uh how many meapar
sex which is a unit of distance objects
are from us and uh we talk about speed
in kilomet per second so at the end
you'll hear us talk about numbers like
70 uh kilomet per second per Mega Parc
as our unit and it's really a unit of
inverse time because it's really how
long do I have to wait until this
universe will double again yeah and so
as the the diagram just illustrates just
to underscore the point you just made
the Hubble constant the Hubble parameter
it tells us how quickly space is
expanding so if a Galaxy is moving away
from us at a speed V when it's at a
given distance when that distance
increases by one MEAP parac its speed of
recession will increase by about say 70
kilometers per second but we put
question marks there because we don't
know exactly what that recessional speed
actually is we think it's on the order
of 70
km/s and one of the one of the issues
that we're going to get into in just a
little while is that both of you have
been spending a lot of time measuring
the expansion rate of the universe and
you're getting different answers so
we're going to come to that in a moment
but part of the issue is can we resolve
the the question marks that we have up
there but I want to bring back
Einstein's equations for just a moment
if we can because even if you don't
follow the mathematics of Einstein's
equations the important thing is on the
right hand
side is a mathematical object that
basically captures all the mass and
energy in the universe and the equations
show that all mass all energy
contributes to how space expands so it's
really important to know what matter and
energy is out there and one of the
things that has happened across the 20th
century into the 21st is the recognition
that what we see is not all that there
is so so Joe maybe you could just what
was the first indication that there's
some stuff out there that we don't see
yeah so so this right the stuff that we
can see are all the stars and in these
beautiful galaxies but since it's been a
hundred years since we've had this idea
that there's a bit more out there things
we can't see it was actually Fritz Wiki
back in the
1930s was looking at a huge cluster of
galaxies so when the Galaxies themselves
live in these big clusters of the
gravity pulls them together and they
were moving too fast in it and that's
the motion of stuff is in a wonderful
way of weighing things and seeing if
there's anything invis visible out there
you know you can gravity just says if
something's heavier something moves fast
around it and you don't have to be
visible to move around it and so he just
sort of noticed that the galaxies were
moving too fast in this in this galaxy
cluster as if there was missing Mass
stuff you couldn't see with your
telescopes um but and he actually called
it in a a paper at the time a paper at
the time Dark Matter dunal Materia right
in his paper but then it lay dormant for
like 30 years the were the were
measurements but it it it was there
weren't there wasn't the kind of
technology to chase up on it and then
was it ver ruin who kind of yeah ver Ru
yeah this beautiful thing with her
colleague Kent Ford went again to look
at things moving to say how fast are
things going and they went and looked at
these um disc galaxies bit like our own
spinning
around and and by looking at them Edge
on they actually use the similar effect
that Eva was talking about before about
this Doppler effect that if you look at
them Edge on and you see how much the
light like gets stretch red or blue each
side you can figure out how fast it's
going and how fast the stars are going
and the stars were going too fast they
were zipping around the edge of the
galaxies too quickly and there had to be
something there something with gravity
that was so I like to think about that I
don't know if it's a good metaphor or
not but I like to think about you know
water drops on a bicycle tire and they
would be flung out if it if they weren't
held in and those Stars should be flung
out if they weren't being held in by
something that we're not seeing and that
be the dark and the dark matter I just
stepped on the um you know you never
make that mistake I'm sorry because uh
so that's one quality of the world that
we gained insight into the existence of
Dark
Matter Adam you you were of course vital
in helping us to understand the
existence of another dark substance
something called Dark Energy so can you
just give us a sense of your journey in
in in revealing this component of the
world yes so bringing the story up till
about the 1990s or so um we knew there
was a lot of Dark Matter out there and
uh this should have been slowing the
expansion of the universe and so the
question was is there so much of it that
it's going to stop the expansion of the
universe that it will recollapse in the
future or um is there so little that it
will expand forever and so uh the way to
figure this out was not just to measure
how fast the universe is expanding now
but to look even further out which is
looking further back in time and measure
how the expansion rate has been changing
over the last few billion years that is
to measure the trajectory of the
universe so we started looking at these
objects called supern noi which are
exploding Stars we could see them far
away so from how bright they are we
could tell how far away they are and
when all was said and done uh we sat
down to measure okay so how much is it
slowing and in fact we found it was
speeding up um it's accelerating and
matter wouldn't do this even Dark Matter
wouldn't do this it would require
something very much like Einstein's
blunder uh the cosmological constant
because in Einstein's gravity uh you can
have gravity go the other direction if
the material out there is not matter-
likee but it's energy likee so this is a
page from my lab notebook showing the
day that uh I was writing down the
results from our first measurements and
I was trying to figure out what the
decer was so I was trying to determine a
number called Omega matter which is how
much matter is in the universe based on
the fit to the data and I kept getting
back a negative number for Omega matter
which you know that doesn't make any
sense but you know as physicists know
you know computers don't know physics so
my computer had only been given the
option of this one number and it said I
could fit the data I just need to flip
the sign of that number and at that some
point I realized okay that isn't proper
physics we need something else that can
play that role and and that was uh
Lambda and and I mean did you know that
you had it at that moment or was that
just sort of I mean nobody believes
there first you know I mean I was just
writing my lab notebook what the first
results were you have to go through a
lot of work to confirm it and you know
you're you assume you make a mistake and
you know we do that all the time so uh
that's just the first moment that it
didn't change now now
remarkably when you take into account
the dark matter and the dark energy if
you look at sort of an accounting of the
ingredients that make up the world if
show a little pie chart it's mostly dark
stuff compared to light so so we're
looking at the relative proportions of
each 68% or so of the mass energy budget
of the universe is in Dark Energy about
5% is in ordinary visible matter and 27%
is in dark matter so the dark stuff is
is by far the vast majority of the
ingredients that make up the mass energy
of the universe so so Eva just tell us
what we're looking at here in terms of
the ingredients that make up the world
so the numbers may not be exactly the
right numbers but what are we seeing in
this pie chart right we're seeing uh the
dark matter which could be many
different things and there's a very
interesting quest to test as much about
that as we can and then the the dominant
comp is the 68% dark energy that Adam
just uh reviewed his discovery of um and
that's uh you know an extremely
interesting component we can model it in
a very simple way in fact but it it
carries with it Mysteries that go beyond
simply how to model it um that we might
get into if we get a chance yeah so we
definitely will in the next part because
I'd like to then investigate can we
drill down and understand what the dark
matter and the dark energy is but before
we get there Joe how do we how do we
test these ideas just to make sure that
we have confidence that we're we're
going in the right direction that it's
got some dark energy some dark matter
and so forth how do we do that so we
combine tons of data so that I mean I
think what's kind of amazing right now
is what a wealth of astronomical data
we've combined together to get that pie
chart it's not one it's not one thing
that gives that it's multiple things um
I'm a little biased because the thing I
use is is something it gives us a bunch
of those numbers but not all of them
which is this image of the very early
Universe you go back and uh if you can
go back and look at the beginning of the
universe it was much simpler than this
exactly this is this you know Blobby
Strang looking image but it's actually a
picture of a snapshot of just a part of
the universe when it was only 400,000
years old um the universe was super
boring back then there were no there
were no stars no galaxies these little
Lum these ripples are just little
actually they were little lumps and
bumps in a sea of particles back then
that's all there was there was nothing
else just and color codes are are
temperature variations they're
temperature but you can think of them as
just measuring like where there were
like slight over densities or under
densities in in the sea of particles
yeah and and but the physics was really
simple we love as physicists we love it
if if things can be simple and back then
these were like just ever so slightly
tiny ripples that gravity had put in and
we can follow the physics pretty well
and so we're able to sort of uh you know
these these ripples are actually kind of
the result of like we think the big bang
and you know a physical process a little
bit like dropping Pebbles into a pond
and Rippling outwards and what we do is
we use our physical we we take our
theories and we sort of try and predict
what what's in this image um and so how
how well do the theories do and trying
to explain pretty awesome so so what are
we looking at here this is like a a
selection of of of data uh that we've
actually gathered more more we've
continued to gather over these
intervening years what is this it's just
you know data points um you take that
image and you break it down and you say
how featureful is it on different scales
like over here is like really large
scales over here is smaller scales but
the important thing really is that if
you look at those black data points this
is measured from the dou map satellite
plus some other data the black data
points are this measurement of this
Lambda
CDM uh sorry the measurements of the
observations but that that line going
through them that like gray pink curve
is the prediction of this Lambda CDM a
current model and it's such a great fit
to the data extraordinary I mean we're
looking at photons that have been
traveling through the universe for more
than 13 billion years measuring those
photons and finding that they fit the
theoretic iCal prediction in this
spectacular Manner and no doubt this is
why as you make reference to the Lambda
CDM Lambda is the dark energy CDM cold
dark matter we call it cold because the
dark matter is not moving too quickly
but this is the standard bear of our
cosmological understanding of the
universe and here's sort of a dynamic
unfolding from the early times of the
universe you've got the cosmic microwave
background about 3 70,000 years after
the beginning then the first stars
formed galaxies and planets and the
whole thing is about 13.8 billion years
in duration and you can actually even
see the accelerated expansion look at
the envelope of the white lines that's
of course what Adam you and your
colleagues found the speed up of the
expansion of space is indicated by the
upturn of the envelope as you head over
to the right so this is a nice visual
summary of the Lambda CDM model the
state-of-the-art
understanding this is all quite
wonderful and it takes us to chapter 2
where we now want to ask
ourselves are there cracks forming in
this model and if there are can they
simply be patched up or might they be
seeds of a revolution in our
understanding and to get a handle on
that there five questions that I think
can guide us here in part two so if we
can just sort of see them the questions
that I have in mind are say what is dark
matter we describe it but what actually
is it made of what is the dark energy
you talk about this energy that's dark
but can we say what it is what sparked
the Big Bang right the initial thing
that got everything to move in the first
place do we know the expansion rate and
that's where we'll have some interesting
questions of details where the Precision
nature of cosmology will come to the
four and in trying to Res resolve that
particular issue we'll ask ourselves do
we really understand gravity which is
what's behind this allall and evea is
going to tell us well I don't know what
she's going to tell us maybe we do maybe
we don't but let's just jump right in
now to the first of those questions what
is dark matter and I'm going to turn to
Eva on this it's a little bit unfair but
um like do we understand what the dark
matter is where do we stand in that
question well we it's not a puzzle in
the sense that there are plenty of
candidates that are that are good you
know well understood candidates and uh
people are doing the best they can to
try and experimentally observationally
probe different possibilities um so um
this ranges from you know big colliders
that try to find things like what are
called certain particles called super
particles to um various kinds of
experiments um that probe a different
kind of quantum field called an Axion
field and um the mo the best we can do
to discriminate among those
possibilities you know the better um
it's clearly it's an important component
of the universe uh we see it
astrophysically of course uh but it's
you know it's not a crack it's not a
puzzle it's just a question yeah it's a
good question um but but here's the
question and I'm interested what folks
who come I mean even I come from the
theory side you guys are you know from
the observational
side we have been as a community
searching for the dark matter for a
really long time many experiments have
been built to try to capture what we
believe are the little particles so even
mentions one possibility the super
symmetric particles that come out of
some of our theories having come up
empty-handed for all this time let me
start with you even then we'll go down
the line do you have
any sense that maybe it's
wrong I do not not doubt all the
evidence for dark matter it's prodigious
and you know Joe did a great job of
summarizing the history of that um I'm
not particularly bothered that we didn't
see these particular candidates they
they're they're very interesting
candidates there was nothing though that
said it's you know so compelling it must
be the the the way the world Works in
fact um this case of super symmetry is a
very interesting one um it's it's it's a
what it sounds like it's a symmetry it's
you know mapping one thing into another
that can be very elegant but it's also
very special and so elegant
mathematically mathematically elegant um
in a certain way um but also very
special and there's a book of that of
that title I think out there but but
yeah yeah go ahead yeah yeah absolutely
yeah thank you um uh but that's why this
dichotomy between that sort of scenario
and say a scenario involving other kinds
of quantum Fields there's a kind called
Axion which are you know from well you
mentioned String Theory from the point
of view of string theory gravity always
comes out and as far as I know axons
also are quite generic in the theory
whereas super symmetry requires very
very special choices um and so I've been
you know working on this following this
for for years and um I'm excited to see
how far we can go but not bothered that
we didn't see super partners for example
um how about you guys I mean do you ever
question it or yeah I mean I would say
the existence of Dark Matter actually as
a particle is certainly the oddson
favorite but the longer we go without
finding it the more concerning it is to
me as an empiricist I mean if it's going
to be science right it can't be a just
so story we have to find the direct
evidence of it um you know you have to
always remember at the end of the day we
are inferring these things Dark Matter
dark energy from gravity and we don't
know that we have the ultimate theory of
gravity either so you know at some point
you you want some ground truth you want
to find the Dark Matter particle I mean
there's other particles in the history
of science the nutrino was a good
example where you could hypothesize it
it must must be there energy is going
away from a reaction and then you find
it and you're like great and then you
know you're on the right track so I
would say you know if decades go on and
we don't find dark matter you know it's
a problem we can't just you know say
well it will be there uh it must be
there we have to find it yeah Joe how
about you well I I mean I think it I
don't know if it's a problem I think
it'd be sad I think I'd be very like it
be it be depressing but I think it could
possible we won't find it it's could it
could just be that making up 25 % of the
energy in the universe five times more
penal than us and it could just be there
and we don't we're not able to see it it
could be completely non-interacting and
we just don't find it but I do I'm a
little bit hopeful there are some hints
that at small scales when we look out at
the universe that like the structures
that we see maybe aren't quite big
enough on very small scales and it could
be a h hint of a do matter but it's by
no means we're not we're not seeing
something strong yet so given that that
that would say that this particular
issue is a crack that will patch over
but what about the possibility just you
know a quick response Eva people have
put forward distinct theories of gravity
that can do away with the dark matter at
least the proponents claim and they say
it's just a figment of your theoretical
imagination that this's this dark matter
stuff it was really your understanding
of gravity that was wrong does that has
that ever moved you uh well quickly let
me just say I think it's a great
question to ask people have asked it it
turns out as far as I understand to be
pretty difficult to get that to work
except perhaps for situations where
really what's going on is it is normal
gravity plus a certain extra kind of
field like a scaler a light very light
field that you know affects how so
you're kind of back to Dark Matter well
you're you're back to and it's nothing
you know as dramatic as would be a
revolution in in gravity that upends at
long distances Einstein's theory y
absolutely all right so that's question
question number one question number two
dark energy so so so Adam you know this
was you know a discovery that that you
really brought back this possibility of
of of dark energy to the four but again
if I was to ask you what actually is the
dark energy you know have we ever you
know bottled some of the Dark Energy
again the answer much like with dark
matter would be no where does that leave
you in your think
do we do we need to identify it nail it
down or is it enough right I mean we
have we're building space missions right
now that are dedicated to studying what
is the dark energy and they're
groundbased missions as well um and so
we have VAR specific questions about
Dark Energy there are different possible
flavors that it can have so it can be uh
the built-in energy of empty space what
we call vacuum energy um it could be
just the energy of a field that happens
to be present in space that isn't so
wacky sounding we're familiar with
Fields there's the electric field the
magnetic field um in both of these cases
there's even sort of existence proofs
for Dark Energy there is we think uh an
episode shortly after the big bang that
really gave the push to the Big Bang
called inflation and we believe that was
due to a field in space acting like dark
energy but there are also sources of
static uh Dark Energy uh vacuum energy
like the Casmir effect that we can can
we actually bring up we have a little
bit of u a graphic on on Casmir energy
and uh I I'll leave it to whoever Eva
Joe do you want to I don't know if you
want to jump in
on can you just give a little sense of
what Casmir energy is and the reason I
ask and and the reason you brought it up
is here's an example where we're
actually measuring a certain kind of
energy in empty space so it makes it
more than just a just so
story yes so it's it's a beautiful thing
so Fields have been discussed the
quantum uncertainty principle was
mentioned and what we're talking about
is essentially that at every Point
Fields undergo some fluctuations that
are irreducible because of the
combination of those those two things
the uncertainty principle now when it
comes to the dark energy or the
cosmological constant the those
fluctuations of the fields which can
occur on any wavelength um sort of if
you push the theory to shorter and
shorter wavelengths it looks like that
contribution just builds up more and
more and so the mystery is not why we
see the dark energy it's why is it the
size that it is the Casmir phenomenon is
a beautiful thing where essentially if
you have as is depicted there some
physical walls or even you could think
abstractly about boundaries to space but
it could be two metal plates right could
could in real Labs it's it's something
like two metal plates you know in
relativity could be a a geometry with a
boundary but either way um there's a
residual of that you know very short
distance effect that actually survives
at long distances and gives a little
Force gives a little push on the on the
on the plates and the presence of the
plates when you sum over all of these
little fluctuations in the presence of
the plates you know making sure that the
fields behave themselves at the
boundaries of the domain as they as they
must according to our equations then you
find this residual which is the Casmir
Force right so in some sense by putting
these two plates in empty space you
create a slight imbalance in these
Quantum fluctuations in empty space
outside versus inside and that winds up
exerting a force that for instance can
push these plates together in empty
space there's nothing there and yet they
put these plates in there and they're
drawn together not gravitationally but
because of the energy of empty space you
can measure this which means that this
idea of energy in empty space is
something real and it's measurable but
as you say Eva it's not something that
we understand when it comes to the
cosmos for instance as you're saying if
we do the most naive
calculation regarding the amount of
energy that there should be in empty
space how does it compare with the
energy in empty space that has actually
been been measured by Adam and
collaborators yeah I mean this does
depend on these questions about what
completes our particle physics but it's
you know many orders of magnitude bigger
no matter what but like how many orders
of
magnitude well it does depend how you
parameterize it but the most dramatic
would be 120 120 orders of
magnitude yeah as as an
yeah yeah we're being a little tramatic
in the way we describe 60 really 60 but
but 60 orders of magnitude that's a
pretty big mismatch between the so
there's really an issue here and and so
again is this a little crack or is this
really telling us something well so you
have the equation up and I hate to refer
too much to it but you had the Lambda
term you had other terms right in the
Einstein field Ein field equations you
pointed to the right hand side of that
equation at one point and you know in
theoretical physics we understand where
those kinds of things come from and
there is plenty that can contribute with
both signs and cancel yeah out to a
residual small effect we would like you
know more to understand more about that
but it's not you know I guess to use uh
a word used earlier it's not a wacky
possibility it's a you know it's it's a
possibility that makes sense yeah um it
could even be what we call a selection
effect where if if we weren't in a
situation where that had happened
everything would be so different this
you know ginormous Quantum fluctuation
that that you and I summarized a moment
ago would cause via Einstein's equations
space to curl up so
dramatically that you know there
wouldn't be this uh 120 or 60 hierarchy
however you want to say it um but we
also you know there just the scales
wouldn't be separated and we wouldn't be
able to have evolved at all yeah so you
know it's a reasonable possibility um
you know introduced by various theorists
you know decades ago that the reason we
see the value that we see is we you know
it's not because it's all the only thing
that could have happened but you know
there's no way we would be here to see
it right right so sort of an anthropic
explanation that had it not somehow
canceled out in the way that it does and
maybe it doesn't cancel out everywhere
in the larger universe but our local
environment has the cancellation because
if it hadn't canceled we wouldn't be
here to notice now some people recoil at
that kind of an explanation I know Joe
like how do you does that have any p on
you I mean I I can see how it might it's
possible but I don't like it know I I
buy the argument that we have to be here
as observers to observe and so there've
got to be things that make we have to
have come about in a universe that is
you know productive to life and solar
systems and this kind of thing but I
still I find it a little uncomfortable
if to to go to anthropic and so if we if
we don't actually uh have a first
principle calculation of the dark energy
or an actual experiment that sort of
grabs hold of the dark energy is there a
point at which Adam For example you said
for dark matter we've got to get it in
empirical science right so do you feel
the same way about Dark Energy you know
I think people should be getting the
impression that we've inferred most of
the existence of the Universe from its
gravity yeah but that's not very direct
I mean when we talk about the 4% you're
familiar with we give you the periodic
table there's tons of information and
detail structure it's fine grained then
we come and we talk about dark energy
and dark matter and they sound like the
frictionless massless pulley you learned
about in physics class like it's it's a
concept it's vague it's there but it we
don't have any real meat on the bones on
it so what we do instead is we take the
most vanilla forms that they can have
and we make predictions of what we
should see in the universe and I think
we'll probably move on to one of those
um and we test it and we say did the
most vanilla version match a new
experiment or do we have to start are we
starting to learn about wrinkles
features of the dark manner Dark Energy
so they're not so uh Blank Slate right
Eva well I it's a fantastic discussion
because you know everybody agrees
there's a mystery with dark energy but
people entirely disagree about what the
fundamental mystery actually is is it
the value is it the interpretation
selection effect or not selection effect
is the polite way of saying anthropic
principle by the way but
um trying to just convince Joe
um but you know there the thing about it
that I think excites theorists the most
and we're still grappling with it your
your Discovery you know 20 plus years
later is to do with the the the Horizon
that it generates y the analogy between
that and what people have also heard a
lot about in you know Theory and and
observation recently which is black
holes there's also Horizon and there's a
relation between those things and
thermodynamics and statistical mechanics
so we have a huge amount of um Clues
this is coming back to sort of thought
experimental theoretical Clues but
they're very compelling clues about the
nature of Horizons and that there's a
account of an enormous number of states
associated with Horizons and that's the
kind of thing that we're grappling with
and making progress with and that's you
know with us regardless of whether the
dark energy is actually constant or not
you know that it's it's one number but
it's a very significant number so can we
just drill down in that just a little
bit because it's an interesting analogy
between black holes and the Big Bang I'm
asked about that I don't know if you
guys are all the time you know sort of
the Big Bang seems like the kind of an
opposite of a black hole black hole
pulls everything in the Big Bang pushes
everything out a black hole has an outer
edge called the event Ariz and we
believe that all of the information
within the black hole is stored on the
surface but from the outside we cannot
see beyond the Event Horizon of a black
hole and cosmologically speaking there's
kind of a version of a horizon because
if objects are too far away their speed
of recession will exceed that of the
speed of light and we will not be able
to see them we won't be able to see
Beyond the cosmological Horizon so it's
interesting whereas for a black hole we
can't see beyond the Event Horizon we
are kind of outside of it cosmologically
we are inside that Horizon and can't see
outside of it so there's this
interesting interplay between these two
kinds of Horizons will we be able to
leverage that into the kind of
understanding that will give insight
into things like dark energy do you
think I believe so that is happening um
just like with the black hole case that
you alluded to
the count of these of these degrees of
freedom that that are depicted here very
beautifully um has been done um but in a
very special case we now can do the same
thing in the cosmic Horizon case but
also in a special case down in three
three SpaceTime Dimensions which you
know is not satisfactory since we are of
course in four but the there's a version
of this problem that applies um in those
simpler context so in both cases we have
a way of getting to this count by
starting from something simpler and
evolve in in some space in in in in in
in the space of theories that we that we
understand to where uh it represents
account of the states of the Horizon and
this is going on you know for reasons
that theorists are very confident about
despite it's it's also related to the
famous Hawking radiation yes and these
are all phenomena um that were you know
pretty confident about but these are not
things that the empir empirical
measurements will really be able to
delve into so it's again this dance
between real observations Theory and
thought experiments and this this this
is part of the story of the of the dark
energy which which I view as the the the
main mystery to it but that's because I
don't recoil
it so we'll move on from from dark
energy to two you know final questions
in this section just a moment but I want
to just throw out one thing you know I
i' there's some articles I don't know
how the commun really views them where
some have suggested that if we were to
give up some of the basic assumptions of
cosmology homogeneity that on the
largest of scales one chunk of the
universe is more or less the same as any
other chunk of the universe isotropy
that if you look in the universe in any
direction on average it's all the same
if you give up any of those qualities
there are theories that suggest you
don't need Dark Energy have you ever
been convinced by any of those those
would be the more revolutionary
approaches to dealing with this question
yeah I wouldn't give those up uh I mean
we talk about we talk about the
cosmological principle which is it's
it's almost it's the most logical thing
it just says Uh there's nothing special
about us where we live is not somewhere
special that we are allowed to do
science do physics chemistry whatever
you want treating everything far away
like it's just like here it's just that
it's far away and that's it's an
incredibly powerful idea it would be
bizarre if that were not the case so we
proceed that way because it allows us to
to work I mean you know uh you could be
on The Truman Show otherwise where
people are you know putting up sketches
and things and you go that isn't really
the way the universe is but instead we
go no everything let's assume it's the
same as like it is here it's just far
away we do the science we test it seems
to work very well it would be so bizarre
if it weren't true that that would be
the last thing I would give up and and
also as you say that the testing is key
like I agree we we we think it's like a
fundamental aspect but we do test it
right we we actually get to measure like
light from things that have been
traveling for billions of years in all
directions and they've had no you know
they they they they sample an enormous
span and array of the universe and they
are all telling us that everywhere we
look seems to be obeying these
fundamental rules so nothing that we've
seen says that it's not true so no no no
revolution in there so I want to quickly
uh in just a moment we'll turn to some
of the issues of this specific expansion
rate in which there is some tension
between the two view but in a in a
discussion it's not
personal but uh but you know in in a
discussion where were're Grace with
having Adam and Eva we have to talk
about the creation we have to talk about
about the creation I knew there was a
plan in this yeah yeah right knew that
was inv list so the question is you know
what sparked the Big Bang because all
that we've been talking about here
tonight has not really been creation
right it's been Evolution How the
Universe has changed over the course of
many billions of years and through study
through detailed observations we have
this beautiful model that there's this
dark matter there's this dark energy
space is expanding and it all seems to
fit with the microwave background it's
all all really beautiful but if we push
back to like Time
Zero do we understand how things got
started okay we'll move on from there
then yeah yeah we weren't around till
like the sixth day or yeah right that's
true too we we can't say no
eyewitness um so so what's what's our
best guess I mean Eva what would you say
if you want to try to push back as close
as we can get theoretically I mean
inflationary cosmology is that and and
what what does that Insight give us
right I mean I inflationary cosmology is
a version of that it's not necessarily
what you're asking which is the then
another why question further back but
for sure but inflationary cosmology is
that in the sense that you start with
you know random
noise um which evolves into what we see
and so these Quantum fluctuations that
basically have you know nothing in them
um goes to the something that we that we
have right within the realm of what we
can understand theoretically and it's
been beautifully tested observationally
so you know we we enjoy Thinking Beyond
that but I try not to get too greedy
about that I mean we have various uh
ways of studying what is called you know
quantum gravity for which string theory
is is is a is a well-developed
idea and it's it's not easy to answer
the the question from you know full stop
from start to start to finish yeah so we
we are still in the process of working
our working our way back I would say
yeah please Joe well no maybe this is
controversial but um I don't think we
know for sure that inflation happened
yeah I and maybe that I maybe this can
we quickly but before just to keep the
audience in when we talk about inflation
maybe I'll just give a quick thing and
then Eva please say what you're going to
say so the idea is that much as the dark
energy today and for many billions of
years has been giving rise to an
anti-gravity that is pushing outward
causing the universe to accelerate in
its
expansion the inflationary Theory posits
that there was a little patch of a dark
energy likee substance of a much greater
strength in the earliest moments of the
universe which gave rise to repulsive
gravity that pushed everything apart and
is perhaps what we call the big bang
that outward swelling so this is sort of
the dominant way that we think about the
earliest moments of of the universe but
I mean are are are you pretty convinced
that this is a part of the right story
I'm pretty convinced I mean to be more
um more dispassionate about it perhaps
the you know the thing you can although
it's it is the dominant Paradigm for
good reasons but it it you know we could
say that uh your observations among
other things are consistent with there
having been what we call Super Horizon
perturbation so those those Wiggles
those those um Wiggles are have to do
with sound waves that start from you
know some like a guitar with the ends of
the strings pinned and so um that
pinning is something that in essence has
been has been measured um and the the
beauty of the inflationary uh origin
narrative is is again this thing that it
just combines basic Quantum mechanic
with Quant you know Quantum Fields with
accelerated expansion which is which is
the kind of dominant kind of energy that
you can have um we've already explained
that we don't even we don't understand
why it isn't bigger than it is um and in
that theory uh you get a picture of of
those microwave background you know
Peaks and and troughs um which descends
from the simplest versions of that
theory and could have been you know that
that picture could have been much much
Wilder yeah so so I I view that already
as kind of a functions worth of evidence
for for the idea um you can it's good to
look for Alternatives and that's a very
interesting subject uh that tends to
require studying SpaceTime when it
crunches into singularities that become
you know difficult to understand um
there might be such an alternative but
it's you know it's it's it's not trivial
it's yeah but but I think but to me
because those Alternatives exist the
data I agree the data that we see are
hugely consistent with that inflation
idea but while the possib while the
Alternatives exist I feel like they have
to be allowed to be possible even if
they are unlikely or I I don't know well
so at what level do they exist are they
under theoretical control that maybe
they could still exist even if we don't
yet understand them well enough um but
because they involve a kind of they get
the super Horizon perturbations sort of
by having the universe shrink and the
waves be outside of that shrinking
Horizon that then expands again and
that's a you know that's a very
interesting idea but making um the
calculations of how that works uh is I
think more difficult and but but I
wonder slightly sociologically and then
we'll return to the science there are
some in the community who suggest that
certain ideas take hold in the
community and they become so entrenched
in our thinking that when Alternatives
come along they aren't given sufficient
air
time do you see that I Adam is a
potential issue here yeah absolutely you
know you you constantly have to ask
yourself okay what is the evidence for
that idea or this idea and are there
Alternatives and I agree with you that
um you know especially students first
coming into the field you know they
don't know themselves in a deep way so
they learn from other people oh
inflation is that what everybody says
started everything okay um and uh they
often don't get back to the first
principles and we do have a history in
science of getting stuck on ideas uh
going back in history The Ether you know
is a great example of that you know
we're all moving through the ether and
then you know eventually people do
experiments and go there is no ether so
um I think that evidence is always
critical and some of the things we're
talking about whether it's inflation
Dark Energy dark matter they have a
certain kind of evidence but they don't
have a whole portfolio of evidence that
is of a more direct nature and so that's
why until we have that we will always be
able to ENT entertain and we should
entertain Alternatives yeah now given
that you know there is one final issue
here that I I want to talk about in this
second part which is do we understand
the detailed rate of expansion of space
it's such a very basic question that
we're talking the space is expanding how
fast is it expanding and so I want to
give each of you an opportunity you know
just a couple minutes to explain the
work that you have been doing and then
we'll sort of compare the results that
you're finding So Adam do you want to
just uh take it for few minutes yeah if
I can um get that first graphic up um so
we have this great story Lambda CDM it's
our new standard model and as we've
talked about uh here today we don't
understand Dark Matter deeply we don't
have a deep understanding of dark energy
so we take the most vanilla forms that
they can have and we uh see what they
predict for the whole history of the
universe's growth what we call the
expansion history
so people like Joe and she will talk
about this make Exquisite measurements
of the state of the universe shortly
after the big bang a few hundred
thousand years they're looking at the
the Afterglow from The Big Bang and from
that they're able to read the state of
the universe they're able to essentially
calibrate this model this story and then
using that calibrated model you could
predict the entire expansion history of
the universe all the way to Forever okay
so it's it's a little bit like you know
if you had a marble and you pushed it
down a hill right you could say well I
knew how fast the marble was traveling
and I'm really good at physics so I'm
able to calculate you know all the
periods of deceleration and acceleration
as the marble goes through the whole
roller coaster and at the very end I
will also know how fast it will be
traveling and so uh Joe and our
colleagues do that and they measure they
predict the expansion rate of the
universe today and in our funny units it
should be 67 now what I do is more like
what Hubble did just with much better
telescopes um so I use you could think
of it more like a radar gun today to
look at the the marble traveling yeah so
what what I do is I look at stars in
nearby galaxies of known uh luminosity
and from their brightness determine how
far away they are and like Hubble did I
measure the expansion rate of the
universe now when I was doing this 10
years ago we were seeing a number like
73 Which is higher than the 67 now you
know at some level if we're Optimist
we're like wow that's pretty good I mean
we're we're spending the entire history
of the universe we're only off by 10%
you know that's not too bad right but um
but you know we take that very literally
very seriously are we missing something
so um so we were very concerned many in
our community were very concerned well
maybe the measure our measurements are
wrong we're using Hubble Space Telescope
that's a good telescope but it's 30
years old now um so we got to use the
new telescope so we started looking
again at these same measurements now
with the James web Space Telescope and
if you see that little patch of an image
on the right there the upper patch is US
looking at one of these mile markers
these stars in a distant Galaxy with the
resolution of the Hubble Space Telescope
and below that is the exact same scene
now seen with the James web Space
Telescope and so it's sort of like
looking at an ey chart and trying to
read that sixth line and you're not
really sure you're able to read it and
you know each time you read a letter you
look look at the doctor like is that
right is that right and now we're
reading like the top line and you're
like I'm confident that's an e and I'm
confident that's a g and so we're at
that stage now and if you I can now get
the next slide this is how it's
transformed our measurements so in Gray
are measurements of those individual
stars from the Hubble Space Telescope
and in red are from the James web Space
Telescope so the data like if you look
at the lower plot there it's just
Exquisite it's so much better than what
we had before but it didn't the answer
so that we're still sitting there going
huh it really does look like the
universe is expanding about 10% faster
than this prediction based on our
understanding of the cosmological model
and so some people are saying if it
isn't a problem with the measurements is
it something else in the universe is the
vanilla description of dark matter and
dark energy ultimately not correct is
there another wrinkle is there a
particle do we not quite understand
gravity this is an end to-end test of
the universe and we're not getting a
passing grade right now and that would
be the seeds of a revolution if that was
the final way people have asked me a lot
like and then what does it mean like how
big a deal could this be and you know I
guess the best analogy to me is sort of
like the loose thread on a sweater like
it might be something you just pluck off
and go oh it was just one wrinkle or
does it unravel the sweater and you know
in physics I mean if something doesn't
match it can be hard to say What will
the explanation look like will it be big
or small there are plenty of examples in
the history of science you know one of
my favorite is the procession of mercury
sure um you know Mercury is traveling in
an orbit that isn't quite right
astronomers note this in the 1800s vul
yeah and they go maybe there's another
planet there maybe it's a small wrinkle
well it was just the wrong theory of
gravity that Einstein developed so it
just goes to show you know sometimes it
can be a small thing that is
revolutionary sometimes it's just a
missing Planet yeah so Joe what's your
take on it because Adam made reference
of course to other approaches to measure
not in the universe that's really nearby
but going way back to so tell us about
your work and how you get your answer
yeah sure so we we observe this image of
the cosmic microwave background that the
Blobby red and blue image you saw before
and it's pretty cool so you it's an
image that where light's been traveling
for 14 billion years and actually we
measured the EXP we infer the expansion
rate we assume Lambda CDM okay we assume
assum Lambda is a constant we assume c.
mattera is just something non-
interacting that behaves by gravity we
assume even the properties of inflation
are very simple initial the initial
Pebbles that we dropped in the pond had
a particular very simple
characterization so we assume this model
Lambda CDM and then we say okay that's
going to do some physics and it's going
to generate this behavior that we're
then looking at very far away and then
we use we measure this ginormous
triangle the biggest triangle in nature
basically where if you see yeah you see
that these are this is an image from the
plank satellite um and your eyes I think
can detect a characteristic size of
those blobs right and if you imagine
that sphere around you on the sky it's
about the size of your thumb held at
arms length right your eyes can see
there there are blobs where there's most
most features and that's the physics of
the early universe that's the dropping
Pebbles into the pond at the beginning
but but how big we see them is this
triangle where like imagine it's the
triangle like the length of my arm is 14
billion light years and the size of my
thumb is the size of a blob and and the
and and the and and if I make the if I
try and make the hble constant 73 which
you're telling me it should be uh I have
to actually pull my thumb closer and and
and it's and it's actually going to make
those features uh seem bigger than they
are and so the size of those features
tells me within this model it's got to
be 67 and and and to within the
Precision that like you know it's not
just it's like 67 and a half half with
an uncertainty of a half like it's it
can't get to 73 basically right so it's
past this there's a kind of magical
threshold in physics you know we don't
sweat too much when we're our
measurements are one error bar apart you
know we go that's funny when they're two
error bars apart when they're three we
go you should check your numbers I'll
check my numbers we'll talk again and
you know but when we get to five times
our error bar and that's where're a
little bit beyond that now we go this
wouldn't happen by chance yeah so so
your seats are reversed relative to what
we see up here on the summary but but
this is the discrepancy and for those
who are keeping score at home a little
bit more precisely these numbers are
known you know to the accuracy that that
you guys we're at plus or minus one now
oh but you even better yeah you know
fantastic that was with hobble but but
can make one really critical point so
people may have heard decades ago we
used to argue about this number
but the difference was that's when
people were measuring the same thing
they were both measuring locally what's
so profound about this is we may both be
right and it may be the story of the
universe that allows us to connect the
beginning to the end that is a little
bit different in some way yeah I mean
it's not a trivial matter but it's for
people to understand just that this is
how we're trying to learn about the
universe is to see if these measurements
from opposite ends of the universe
ultimately agree
so Eva what do you what do you think
when you see a discrepancy like this do
you anticipate that it's just going to
resolve that we'll join here two or
three years from now and Joe or Adam
will say ah you know what we just didn't
take it count of X and and the numbers
migrated together or is this a real
discrepancy that we've got to figure out
what the heck it means well you know
these are the experts on that um it's
true that one can find Historical
examples of both kinds where there had
been quoted you know errors outside of
of you know some window um five Sigma is
is a big is a big deal but where
nonetheless it did happen like you say
these so-called anomalies went away and
theorists wrote zillions of papers but
it was kind of wasted effort because in
the end it was you know the Precision
and the you know detail of the of the
measurements so you know I certainly
don't know but I'm super curious about
it and I've been looking into What It
Takes and what people have learned about
about that and um well on the on the
measurement side um we were chatting
offline about kind of a a third sort of
probe which is the statistical
distribution of galaxies the so-called
large scale structure of the universe
has weighed in and and again um it could
whatever model would would account for
this would have to fit fit that data as
well as the CMB and the and the late
Universe um and you know certain models
that had been proposed and and actually
did some good at at you know partly
resolving the tension um uh using CMB
plus plus late those those went away
those those did not fit this other this
kind of third third probe and so people
are actively working on yeah on on that
and and you know once that happens then
any any model building that's to be done
must you know right must account for
that and have you seen anything that you
find particular compelling as an
explanation I there are creative ideas
for sure um so far if if I understand
correctly um and I only really
understand things if I if I've actually
worked on it and I full disclosure I I'm
thinking about it a little bit I haven't
um but from what I understand um the
models do suffer from the addition of
this of say this third type of data but
that you know just adds to our to our um
collection of data to match so now now
Joe do you think this is a real issue I
mean I think you've got confidence in in
your measurements uh I what do you
think's going to be five years from now
well okay so I mean I gained I gained
more confidence in this measurement
because we did it with two different
telescopes so this this came from the
plank satellite and then just uh you
know the last few years we made a new
image of that micro background with our
telescope the had a Karma cosmology
telescope in Chile and and we got a
number that agree this isn't yeah this
is an image of the you basically can
look in it's a telescope that gives you
five times the resolution because it's 6
meter in diameter and this is like a
zoom in on part of this new image of the
microwave background and so you can just
see it in higher definition and and
there lumps and bumps in high definition
and it and we we got 67 with this as
well um we've got new data ready to be
looked at that will tell us you know
even better but so where am I now I I
think I think it's super interesting and
we should we be working on it and and a
lot of us and much of my research is
about trying to test these models that
could give 73 with our
data I'm not yet ready to throw out the
CDM so I'm not saying that your results
aren't correct but I I'm I think it's
super interesting and I think we should
be looking for it yeah um yeah so so
time will tell time will tell um yeah I
mean you know one thing I would add to
it and I'm in a similar position with
Joe uh you we we saw this with the
Hubble Space Telescope so then we used a
new telescope the James web Space
Telescope and we see it there so you
know we think this looks pretty
compelling as well um you know my
reading sort of of the history of
science is things come and go anomalies
and whatnot but this one's been around
for 10 years now and our community is
very good at jumping on things when
they're interesting and finding problems
and issues all this data is public it's
in the public domain this is is not
somebody's private stash of data you
know the Hubble Space Telescope jamesw
Space Telescope it's there's an archive
from NASA everybody has looked at it um
and so when it's in the public domain
like that people have looked at it and
it last 10 years usually that means at
least something interesting is going on
not just like whoops that was a bug in a
code or something like that but so this
is an example where Precision cosmology
May really reveal some deep surprise I
mean if you're both right it means
there's something new that we haven't
been taking account of in order to
extrapolate from your measurements right
I would say the very least you know I
want to understand why these are the
gold standard tools of measuring the
Universe I mean we're using supern noi
and seats which is how we figured out
the universe was expanding in the first
place how we measured its acceleration
Joe's looking at the radiation left over
from The Big Bang which is how we came
to understand the Big Bang so if these
two tools are disagreeing with each
other that's interesting to me I want to
understand why that is so in in the
final part we don't have much time just
about 10 15 minutes or so if we if we
look toward the future what experiments
observations new telescopes are coming
online that are that are going to help
us wh which ones are you most excited
about maybe begin with you Joe well I
I'll maybe divide that into the things
that I'm excited about that that I'm
involved in and things that other people
are doing that I want desperate to see
their results of so the two things that
that that I'm involved in uh that I
think can weigh in on these questions
are the the final data actually from our
Atacama cosmology telescope which we're
about to you know take a deeper look at
in the next you know come in this next
year and we should actually learn a
whole bunch from that and then the then
the which is there pitched up here it's
now just finished taking observations
and it's coming down but we have tons of
data from it next door to that behind us
there's the Simon Observatory that is
about to start taking data and as well
as testing these models testing the
Hubble expansion rate the other thing
I'm super excited about is that we're
trying to look for this signal from The
Big Bang so gravitational waves produced
from inflation um so the rapid swelling
of space yeah sends out messing up or
juggling jittering the fabric of space
and we can see the after ripples of that
yeah initial expansion yeah exactly I
think that would add if we saw them then
I hope that that would even add to the
compelling so that that that you know we
should be starting getting data in the
next month um and so that will add to
already interesting data coming from the
south pole on this on this topic so to
me those are the things that I'm excited
about from the CNB but I'm also super
excited about um observations of
galaxies distributed throughout the
Universe to look for like as traces of
how the universe has expanded so from
the uclid satellite there's this survey
called uh the uh Desi that's looking for
like the distribution of galaxies
there's a whole Suite of upcoming
observations the Ruben Observatory um
that are going to be like just measuring
the distribution of
galaxies deep into Cosmic time and I
hope this will reveal some of these so
Adam I want to hear your view on that as
well but perhaps just a quick question
many people no doubt have heard that
from the James web Space Telescope
there's already some potential
unexpected maybe anomalous observations
having to do with the mass the
brightness of early galaxies where do
you where do you come down well first of
all tell us what the issue is so so uh
the James Webb Space Telescope is a it's
incredibly powerful it's uh an
incredibly cold telescope which means it
doesn't see its own heat that allows it
to see not just the faintest but the
reddest and therefore the most red
shifted objects so they're the most
distant ones so it has been able to look
further back in time and still see
individual objects than any telescope
and it's looking at the first galaxies
to turn on and what has been surprising
is the first galaxies don't quite look
like babies they look more like
teenagers they look like they already
are uh luminous and a little massive and
uh uh nothing against teenagers if
there's any in in the audience but they
look a little more evolved too mature
little too mature yeah um and uh and
we're struggling to understand that now
the I think the reasonable
interpretation of this is something
speeds up this process and that will fit
within our understanding of how galaxies
evolve and form um you know uh it's just
more efficient at uh gravity at at
taking matter and converting it into
stars um there's less dust to block
light uh there are larger black holes in
the beginning that are bringing things
in um but it's also possible that it
could connect to some of these concerns
or issues we have about cosmology about
gravity about the presence of black
holes early that could have a kind of um
disruptive effect in the early plasma of
the universe so I think it's worth kind
of keeping track of it's not something
that keeps me up at night in the same
level yeah um but what I'm looking
forward to is a few more years of James
Webb Space Telescope data this is just
Early times then I'm looking forward to
we talked about gravitational waves um
there are alternative ways to measure
distances in the nearby Universe using
not light but gravitational waves
systems like this that you see um where
a black hole is spiraling into what we
call uh a neutron star or even two
neutron stars so that uh what you get
when they spiral in is a kind of
explosive event where if there's at
least something that is not a black hole
in the system then you will create some
light that you can see and a telescope
an optical telescope can pick that up it
can measure the red shift of the host
Galaxy but you measure the distance not
with light the way I do but with the
strength of the gravitational waves so
this is an alternative way to measure
the expansion rate of the Universe um
Joe was just mentioning to me she would
love to see local measurements done in a
totally different way that would be a
totally different way um so that would
be great I also look forward to uh uh a
facility NASA is launching the Roman
Space Telescope which should better
measure supern noi that we first
measured the dark energy with and really
characterized the recent expansion
history of the universe one possibility
we didn't discuss is you know it could
be that the universe is just kind of
taking off in its expansion sort of
superp expanding beyond what even a
cosmological constant would do um and
that could tie into what we're seeing so
we need a better measure of the recent
trajectory of the universe yeah so Evo
you know when it comes to understanding
gravity which is the underlying force in
the entire discussion here tonight we've
been struggling for you know a long time
string theories an approach that tries
to push our understanding of gravity
even further but can you imagine or are
you anticipating any experiments that
will give us insight into whether we are
making progress on that fundamental
question I it's it's definitely nuanced
but but I do and actually Joe stole my
answer actually of the you know the
primordial gravitational ways it's been
a you know it's an epic story of uh
their you know the search for those um
their meaning it's it's a little bit
like what we said earlier about atom's
discovery of the cosmological concepts
like one number so far um doesn't need
to vary doesn't vary necessarily but
it's as significant as one number can
possibly be it changes the causal
structure of SpaceTime if one were to
measure um primordial gravitational
waves it would be again even if it's a
single measurement without any
substructure it would be um extremely
informative um this this way of
parameterizing our our great ignorance
of of quantum gravity that we touched on
earlier basically says you know with
vanilla assumptions you know minimal um
putting our thumb on the scale that
these fields in the early Universe um in
in the event of such a detection when
when a they
moved just like a sort of particle but
but the field itself changes its value
um by an amount that's of order the
fundamental scale gravity and that is a
that is a rare instance where something
that implies big sensitivity to quantum
gravity is also about the place where
observers think they can get on this
measurement and this is something that
we've been greatly engaged in in um
modeling in in detail um the let's say
for sake of argument the inflationary
Dynamics in the context of string theapy
because it does require that um and
finding you know some of these large
field examples that are that are
honestly testable by this method and so
it's not that we can take those
measurements and reverse engineer the
full theory of quantum gravity but it's
an interface that's that's you know
really legit and and exciting and and a
huge piece of circumstantial evidence at
the very least if there's a positive
outcome yeah I mean there's there's many
um aspects to this uh another example
would be more about the statistics of
these early Universe fields we sort of
have been talking about them as
basically random in a certain sense what
we call like a normal distribution um
but there's actually many um ways that
they could easily deviate from that
interactions could um imprint themselves
on our observables and there ways to
look for those in new ways in existing
data and also in data that that might
might come along um some programs that
maybe culminate in something people call
Mega mapper would be an example where
you get as much of of this uh stuff
about the statistics of galaxies as as
you can possibly collect so yeah I'm
very excited about the the future and
this interface so it it is an enormously
exciting and fruitful time one final
question for all of you let me just
start with with Eva so so we began this
conversation you know search for Cosmic
Origins right we've certainly
illuminated Cosmic Evolution we noted
that we really don't as of today know
how things really got started why it got
started at all
do you think we will answer that it
could be a quick yes or no or go as deep
as you want I mean is that a question
that we will be able to
address you know I I could imagine both
scenarios right uh so that's not a very
useful answer but it's the honest truth
in one scenario we you know it's already
amazing how far back we can go and we
you know go a bit more but that's you
know that's that's where we end up um
but it could be that when we grapple
with the the theory and we have many
questions about the theory that we know
we have partly from empirics and partly
just from our internal understanding
what the issues are there are serious
issues and you know
once you know one can imagine that we
resolve them or or the AI resolves them
or what what you know whatever it is
that happens leads us to um a package
that is completely self-contain and
makes you know predictions for what came
before what is outside the Horizon and
so on so I don't know but both
possibilities are are still alive Joe
where do you come down on that I I
really hope so I I think we have I think
I have to think that we can because
that's partly why we do a lot of this
stuff is to try and think that we can
understand it I I don't think it'll be
us I think it's longer than that right I
I mean if we don't answer it uh Adam or
Joe however you want to take it uh in
some sense are we reduced to the level
of mythological storytelling I mean it's
a precise version of it because at some
point we really do understand what's
going on but without a complete story do
you feel that we're somehow maybe you
know in kinship with those of our
forbears who were trying to just come up
with a narrative I mean I think we're
better at acknowledging the areas of
ignorance we have I don't think at the
end we're going to go you know and
that's where you know the God of Dark
Matter Reigns and you know takes over I
don't think we will go down that road um
but you know I would say in terms of the
question is it knowable or not you know
I mean the most humbling thing about all
of this is you know unlike a good book
or story where they leave you Clues so
you could figure it out at the end I
mean there's no guarantee that the
universe is built for us to understand
it so you know we'll go as far as we can
with the clues that are out there but
you know some things might be hidden
from us that you know are just never
going to be on a human scale to to know
may well be but but also the origin I
mean we it's extraordinary really how
much of our origin story we have figured
out right you you're asking a lot to go
even further back right we we we can go
14 billion years back and go to like a
sea of particles that then evolves over
14 billion years and makes us and we can
even run computer programs that say yeah
I can follow that through like that is
amazing and that is an origin story yeah
no it's an amazing thing that a brain
that evolved on the AFC Savannah in
order that we could survive to get the
next meal to be able to build shelter
has somehow been able to go beyond the
needs of mere survival and learn so much
about our own Cosmic Origins so please
join me in thanking
[Music]
everybody